[Musique]
non non non tu sais ce qu'est une nounou de nuit
ils s'occupent du bébé la nuit
pour que maman et papa puissent dormir un peu
je suis toujours étranger dans ma maison c'est comme
un film à vie nous sommes la nounou essaie
de tuer le  la famille et la maman ça
survit et elle doit marcher avec une canne
à la fin
se remettre de toi maman ce qui ne va pas pour
ton corps bonjour
je suis à la télé
je suis là pour prendre soin de toi je n'ai juste
pas l'habitude que les gens fassent des choses  pour moi
je tiens un bébé toute la journée et puis la nuit
arrive et je suis censé
changer de vitesse comme bonjour je suis tout sexy maintenant
tu es vide
[Musique]
ouais non tu es vide de ce côté
tes 20 ans sont super  mais ensuite votre
trentaine arrive au coin de la rue comme un
camion à ordures à 5 heures du matin
.  Je suis convaincu que votre échec,
mais vous signifie en fait que votre plus grand
rêve devient réalité si vous voulez vous
enfuir pour quelque chose et l'obtenir.  t parce que je
veux faire ça aussi parfois je ne vais pas
Je suis là pour t'aider avec
tout et je ne peux pas réparer les parties
sans traiter le tout ouais personne n'a
traité mon Oh depuis très longtemps
[Musique]